[Musique]
qu'est-ce que l'émerveillement gens
qu'on connaît tous ce mot c'est pas si
évident de le définir
alors plutôt que des mots je vous
propose de l'imaginer j'aimerais que
vous fermez les yeux
je vous rassure pas de danger pas de
risque ne vous auriez pas non plus la
suisse serait beaucoup moins
intéressante germes avec vous vous
rappeliez un jour de noël
quand vous étiez enfant imaginez
l'ambiance sapin les cadeaux ce moment
où vous les découvrirez avec avec toute
votre surprise et votre joie vous
rappeler de ce que ça fait c'est ça
l'émerveillement alors vous pouvez
ouvrir les yeux parce que maintenant la
suite si vous n'avez pu faire mais c'est
vraiment pas pas pratique et à présent
je vais montrer quelques photos de
personnes qui ont été émerveillés et à
vous de voir qu'est-ce qui a pu les
faire agir comme ça voici la première
photo
j'aime beaucoup la réaction de surprise
de la dame
mais la prochaine est une de mes
préférées regardez vous avez vu la file
sur la droite s'ajuste pas de prix on a
le crédit us quand même incroyable c'est
l'une des meilleures réactions qu qu'on
puisse imaginer
allez une petite dernière un peu plus
évidente vous avez vu les toits qu'elle
a dans ses yeux les étoiles comme ma
deuxième derrière ça c'est juste génial
bon alors au cas où vous n'auriez
peut-être pas deviner toutes ces
personnes ont réagi à la même chose un
tour de magie
j'ai découvert ma passion pour la magie
à mes 17 ans quand je me suis rendu
compte que je pouvais ressentir cette
émotion tout simplement en la créant
chez les autres en tant que magicien
j'aime pour c'est que la magie est une
forme d'art
là où les films la musique la danse
permet de véhiculer des émotions
j'aime penser que la magie
l'art de la surprise et l'émerveillement
et comme toute autre forme d'art
je pense que elle a un langage qui n'a
pas de frontières grâce à cela j'ai pu
vivre aventure incroyable et rencontrer
des gens que je n'aurais jamais pu
rencontrer de ma vie
sans cette clé pour émerveiller mais
alors comment fonctionne un tour de
magie et bien ce soir je vous propose
d'entrevoir l'envers du décor ou comment
créer l'étincelle d'émerveillement grâce
à la magie
tout d'abord j'aimerais vous parler de
tome i wonder tommy mondor est une
légende pour nous les magiciens et il a
écrit en 1996 les books of wonder les
livres de l'émerveillement car que là on
peut pas faire plus dans thème c'est le
livre pour émerveiller tu veux
émerveillé tu prends ces livres c'est
parfait c'est génial des magiciens
cesser une bible pour nous et dans ceux
dans cet ouvrage qui fait quand même
plus de 1000 pages il ya une partie qui
est très intéressante qui concerne la
construction du tour quand on veut
modifier quelque chose de physique comme
un bout de bois par exemple eh bien on
utilise un outil qui est tout aussi
physique comme une scie une tronçonneuse
quelque chose de physique mais la magie
se passe dans l'esprit des spectateurs
alors c'est notre esprit que l'on va
devoir utiliser pour modifier le leur
comme nous ne sommes pas télépathe
je sais en n'est pas télépathe on va
devoir utiliser des biais physique pour
véhiculer l'image du tour que l'on veut
transmettre jusqu'au cerveau du
spectateur et ça passe par les trois
pieds de la magie la technique la
mécanique et la psychologie commençons
pour la première la technique
la technique est basée sur l'habileté à
va nous permettre de déplacer
transformer métamorphose est téléporté
quelque chose n'importe quoi soit de
manière visuelle pour créer un effet
magique soit de façon invisible pour
plus tard créé cet effet magique
on retrouve cet exemple particulièrement
dans les démonstrations
on de triche au poker quand malgré
d'innombrables mélange diverses et
variées les tricheurs au poker aviv
malgré tout improbabilité à retrouver
les 4 as par exemple il suffirait que
ouais on va partir ici et retrouver par
exemple valu quatre os
par exemple j'aurais préféré que ce soit
aussi facile pour trouver mes clients
général anglais c'est plus compliqué
ce qui est intéressant dans la technique
c'est que peu importe la situation plus
vous aurez de techniques que vous serez
à même à faire ce que vous voulez peu
importe la situation
peu importe le 2e pilier c'est celui de
la mécanique alors la mécanique a le
même but que la technique c'est à dire
créer soit un effet magique tout de
suite soit faire quelque chose pour qu
un effet magique plus tard mais lui il
va être plus bas plus basé comme son
indic sur des mécanismes exemple la
femme coupée en deux ou la femme qu'on
met dans une boîte et qu'on plante bp où
l'on fait beaucoup de choses aux fans
quand même un détour
mais l avantage de la mécanique c'est
que là où on est purement basée sur
l'habileté dans la technique la
mécanique va nous permettre soit de
faciliter les choses là où la télé
serait beaucoup plus difficile soit de
carrément faire des choses que la
technique en elle-même serait totalement
incapable de faire tout seul ainsi quand
il fait froid
[Applaudissements]
alors certaines personnes se base
uniquement sur la mécanique parce que il
estime qu' ils n'ont pas assez d'aisance
au niveau de la technique
d'autres al'inverse soit par fierté ou
parce qu'ils ne font pas assez confiance
à la mécanique se base purement sur la
technique mais tous utilisent le
troisième pilier celui de la psychologie
la psychologie c'est un peu la clé de
voûte de la construction du tour on va
la retrouver par exemple dans le béton
demande attention quand je vous dit de
regarder à droite et que tout se passe à
gauche ou les illusions d'optique ou les
petites et subtilité qui vont vous
permettre d'assimiler subtilement des
informations vraies ou fausses
pour que le moment venu toutes ces
hypothèses que vous aurez pu imaginer
pour deviner comment a fonctionné le
tour est bien et s'avère totalement
impossible à vérifier impossible à
confirmer par exemple je me rappelle
l'été dernier je me bats leurs
tee-shirts oui ça m'arrive et je vous ai
un tour de magie à à des gens et j'ai
entendu quelqu'un dire mais c'est
incroyable en plus j'ai pas de manche
oui alors c'est pas le but mais comme
vous l'appelez loup comme vous avez pu
le voir implicitement j'ai donné
l'information que vous ne pouvez rien à
cacher dans les manches puisque
invisible ans j'en avais pas c'est ça
toutes ces subtilités qui vont permettre
d'infirmer des hypothèses que vous aurez
pu imaginer mais dans vos rêves les plus
fous
mais alors à quoi ressemble un tour avec
les trois piliers
bah écoutez je vous propose une petite
démonstration si ça vous tente
1 alors qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire
ça on va reprendre le joker de tout
argent qu'à faire un et qu'est ce qu'on
pourra faire si on essayait par exemple
battu ambri essayer de l'effacer tient
alors quitte à effacer une carte autant
tout est passé système ans je veux faire
ça avec mes habits pour les laver très
très pratique alors où sont les trois
piliers comme vous avez pu vous en
doutez j'utilise card seul objet pour ce
tour de magie
donc il ya de fortes chances pas
forcément toujours que la mécanique
résidait dans le jeu de cartes
mais si on pose jusqu'à reporter comme
ça il va pas fonctionner tout seul il
faut bien le manipuler et c'est là où la
technique intervient pour pouvoir vous
montrer et transformer ce jeu de cartes
en jeu totalement vierge il a fallu que
je fasse des manipulations à la fois
invisible pour plus tard pour le moment
j'ai transformé mais aussi de façon
visible pour que vous puissiez voir sous
vos yeux ébahis et un jeu car totalement
blanc et la psychologie dans tout ça
comme vous avez pu voir tout à l'heure
vous ai montré notre effet notre
démonstration de triche au poker pour
trouver les quatre as une production de
4 as comme ça je vous ai montré un jeu
de cartes totalement normal ce qui a
injecté dans votre esprit le fait que je
carte était normal ce qui a pu
totalement invalide l hypothèse que
j'écarte été totalement truquée
et en plus grâce à la technique j'ai pu
confirmer et manipuler le jeu de cartes
de telle sorte à ce que les soupçons ne
soit jamais éveillé mais la psychologie
va encore plus loin ce tour et peut-être
impressionnant mais il n'arrive pas il
manque un ingrédient encore plus
important là où le squelette manque sa
peau ce tour manqué d'un habillage une
présentation la tentation c'est un petit
peu ce qui va rendre le tour plus
organique plus véritable à fred
hitchcock disait qu'il aimait pas les
films policiers écartent pour lui
c'était juste des casse-têtes très
élaborée qui stimule et son intelligence
et pas ses émotions
eh ben c'est pareil pour la musique le
but c'est dans nos remirent le serbe
fait en sorte que rien de suspect de se
passe et ça passe donc par la
justification de tous nos faits et
gestes
pourquoi je sors mon jeu de cartes
pourquoi je le transforme
de quelle façon je le montre tous ces
petits mots geste tagging regard tous
tes parfaitement minutieusement calculé
pour que vous savez votre cerveau ne te
dise il se passe rien
parfait je regarde qu'est ce qui va se
passer une fois la barrière de
l'intellect passé il nous reste plus
qu'à aller chercher l'émotion un grand
magicien darwin ortiz a écrit le livre
strong magic la magie forte à une magie
bodybuildé 1
mais c'est plus un livre t purement
théorique pour potentialiser la réaction
des spectateurs à nos tours de magie et
à l'intérieur il ya un chapitre est
intéressant sur l'attitude du magicien
alors si vous avez déjà vu les tours de
magie dans votre livre vous avez vous
êtes peut-être vous dira oui
effectivement imaginer un malsain qui
arrive il fait regarde bien sous vos
yeux ébahis et je faire apparaître la
statue de la liberté
si on vous dit ça de tte façon à ce
qu'ils vous n'arrivez vous n'arriverez
jamais à deviner comment je vais faire
forcément vous voulez vous mettre mode
ok je te regarde tout allait bien
c'est pas du tout le but parce que là on
va rentrer dans une relation gagnant
perdant si je réussis mon tour ce qui
risque d'arriver puisqu'on on s'entraîne
pour et bien on a réussi autour c'est
parfait les gens sont impressionnés mais
mais mais mais au fond de nous le
spectateur a quand même une sensation
d'avoir perdu pourquoi parce qu'il n'a
pas réussi à deviner comment on a fait
le tour et c'est pas ce n'est pas notre
vie nos bus est émerveillé et al'inverse
si dans son aspect sceptique dans cette
attitude de défi il va vouloir deviner
les choses et dur il va se mettre à
surinterpréter tout bas je t'ai vu tu
t'es gratter le nez au moment où tu as
regardé ma voisine
alors oui je me suis intéressé vrai je
plaide coupable mais ça pas forcément
quelque chose en rapport avec le tour de
magie mais pour lui c'est pas la peine
il a deviné vous avez perdu le médecin a
perdu le spectateur on retrouve une
fierté car il a abattu le magicien mais
encore une fois ce n'est pas le but le
plus et d'émerveiller alors comment on
fait et bien tout simplement en ayant
une posture ouverte en s'ouvrant aux
autres
les gens vont forcément s'ouvrir quand
on tend la main à quelqu'un pour dire
bonjour même si on connaît pas on a
tendance a dû serrer la main un autre
grand magicien jeff mcbride a dit la
magie n'est pas à propos de ce que tu
peux faire ma propos de ce que tu peux
donner
personne ne refuse de cadeaux sincère en
revanche si vous lancer un défi à
quelqu'un vous retrouvez forcément face
à un mur mais alors pourquoi on fait
tout ça c'est à dire qu'on passe des
heures des heures des semaines des mois
des années à faire la même chose le même
mouvement en boucle dans notre salle de
bains dans notre chambre en classe on
façonne miroir devant un tel et peu
importe la situation
on répète ce mouvement encore et encore
pour qu'au final vous voyez même pas
mais un peu maso sur les bords je veux
dire eh bien vous vous rappelez quand
vous étiez enfant quand vous émerveiller
tout vous serez pas que de nos jours en
grandissant on y perd cette capacité à
s'émerveiller
le pack avec la société de nos jours qui
est axé sur l'efficacité et le rendement
se concentre dessus et on s'attarde pas
aux petites choses de la vie
pire encore on attend ça banalise et ses
petites choses tellement elles sont
abondantes
j'ai jamais entendu quelqu'un se réjouir
d'avoir de l'eau chaude
sauf si quelques jours auparavant l'eau
chaude a été coupée et bien notre boulot
à mon sens notre en tant que magicien
c'est de prendre ces petites choses de
la vie
les montres et les rencontres
merveilleuses incroyable et faire en
sorte que tout le monde se disent
wahou ces petites choses de la vie
pouvait être merveilleuse je peux aller
au travail et regardez le lever du
soleil même envoyé devant faire une
bribe de conversation avec mon voisin de
métro toutes ces petites choses de la
vie qui rendent notre quotidien c'est
merveilleux et j'espère en quittant en
quittant cette scène vous dirai je vais
faire attention et s'émerveiller un peu
plus et une étincelle pouvant se
propager
peut-être que vous la transmettrai et
vendrait votre quotidien celui des
autres beaucoup plus magique
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]